um I want to call to order the uh uh
session of the uh special committee on
the
family uh Court uh the subcommittee
dealing with uh perjury and I want to
welcome uh all my committee members and
substitutes for for being here
appreciate that and again um I apologize
I know we had an earlier meeting that uh
where we didn't have a quorum and that
that it's unfortunate but but we're
we're all here today so before we begin
I'm going to ask everyone if you please
Allegiance I pledge allegiance to the
flag of the United States of America and
to the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
all all right so um the way I would like
uh to proceed is this
um this is we've dubb this as a a sort
of work session but if there are people
who would like to be heard um at the
beginning I'm happy to do that one with
a couple of a couple of
caveats first of all I want to make it
clear to everyone we are not going to be
retrying any particular cases we have no
authority to do that and we're not going
to do that secondly the issue here that
of of the the charge of this
subcommittee is the issue of of
perjury um and I guess what I would say
is for purposes of of uh moving this
process
forward let's assume that there is an
issue of a problem with perjury in uh in
general or in family law cases let's
assume that that's true I I think there
might be a question of the extent of it
but let's assume that that's true what I
would like you to direct your comments
up uh on if you wish to be heard is what
do you propose is the solution for that
tell us what you think how the law
should be changed in your view to um to
address that issue and the last thing I
would say is I I'm going to uh limit
people's comments to 3 minutes so please
get to the point tell us what you what
you think uh the the the uh the way that
the law should be changed uh to address
your concerns so with that um I'll call
uh sir would you like to come
up oh yeah you know you uh do we have do
we have pink
card oh yeah if if you wouldn't mind if
to just and you you know you can sir you
can you can tell us what you want to
tell us first but then just fill it out
before you leave if you would please
thank you and anyone else who wants to
thing so my name
is there you go thank you okay it's good
H so my name is Caren bani I live in
Brooklyn New Hampshire so I know that uh
Ju Ju Just to confirm no specific
details about what I believe are
examples of why we need the law change
right so here's something that occurred
that I believe of why I'm
of the type of law that's required in
family court or is that okay right I
would like no I would like you to focus
on what you think you know what you
think uh the solution should be to if if
there's a perjury problem what should be
the solutions absolutely um so I so I
would say l layer one the the the the
New Hampshire Family Division circuit
court rules specifically state that
Rules of Evidence do not apply right and
there's a lot of discretion when it
comes to what that Rules of Evidence is
um the standard for Rules of Evidence
obviously we know have different kind of
Standards right so you have your very
basic probable cause that's not enough
to make a Judicial decision but enough
is in a criminal scenario potential to
pursue charges right in investigation we
know there's preponderance of evidence
and we know that there's Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt family courts are
generally prant of evidence however
there is a conflict between No Rules of
Evidence and preponderance of evidence
this has been something that's common
across a lot of cases so I think that's
number one
uh number two how are we making sure
that folks like Garden at Liams who are
technically under the law expert witness
testimony right not being treated as
100% truth what's happening a lot in
family court is that the why discretion
afforded does not have a basis to
determine the like what is the approach
judges are using to determine
credibility right so I I I'll give an
example especially where where this
becomes really atic uh and I'm open
about this I'll share with you I'm I'm
autistic my wife has ADHD right so neuro
Divergence is very very important to
understand how people come across judges
are using credibility determinations
based on very clearly what stated often
demeanor Behavior eye contact all of
those things at DIS disadvantage because
there's not enough and this is where the
diversity inclusion committee actually
will be huge for for making sure that we
understand how judges are being trained
to understand how to use that power that
whyde discretion is problematic when you
do not have an accurate measure there's
actually a supreme court mg cury brief
that recently happened due to the the uh
the um FTX collapse right so that this
is in the financial crime space but that
gentleman s bang fredman he uh there was
an Ami cury that was submitted that
explains how neurod Divergence manifests
especially in the court system and I
think that's important for New Hampshire
family court system
the the next thing is I would say
attorneys are attorneys properly trained
to make sure that they understand the
difference between cander towards a
tribunal right and their Duty the
problem that I've seen today is
attorneys do not know the line of CER
towards the tribunal versus when you're
zealously advocating for your client and
when that line is crossed and that line
is different in criminal for an attorney
as a criminal defense attorney for
example versus in family court and what
I'm seeing is that the criminal defense
attorneys who are also coming into
Family Court are using criminal defense
CER towards the tribunal standards and
impacting family court right where that
does not apply and judges are not
holding that accountable so again I
can't go into those details in three
minutes but I would say do really
understanding how does CER toward the
towards a tribunal manifest the the the
next layer of that is judges also have a
responsibility on the judicial code of
conduct to make sure that they are
actively reporting issues such as
professional conduct issues whether it's
to the Garden at lighten board whether
it's to the Ado so or do judges have a
good view in what is the line of cander
towards a tribunal when does that go
towards breaching that when does that go
even further to potentially being
criminal right to say perjury these
lines it can't be one is it perjury or
is it not it has to start with well do
we have a how do we determine
credibility right that's the most basic
from credibility you go into is there a
CER towards a tribunal type issue
manifesting here right from the
professionals representing those
individuals then you might go as far as
now is it perjury right and not just
perjury as in the one part of title 641
but any part of title 641 right because
sometimes what's also occurring is you
have this distinction of well
technically they said this under oath
verbally that could be perjury or it's
misdemeanor equivalent but then you also
have a written statement that's the
opposite but the written statement does
not match the verbal statement and is
that technically perjury that's for a
criminal court and judge to decide but
if you have these other layers behind it
it allows Family Court judges to not
have to make a criminal court decision
that's for prosecutors and Criminal
Courts to try but knowing when to refer
it by properly thinking about have I
made a valid credibility decision have I
held the candidate towards a tribunal
standard right if you're not a lawyer if
you're a gardened lier or any other
expert testimony what are equivalent
laws and standards that we can put in
place that are like cander towards a
tribunal so everyone is held to that
standard if you're a professional that's
testifying right then go to Pur all
right thank you questions for this
witness thank you very much sir anyone
heard oh oh yes and the pink card thank
thank you very much
anyone else who would like to be
heard all right
valard and Mr valard if if when you get
a chance I'd ask before you leave if you
would fill out the pin card also thank
you I think you just turned it on there
you go good morning everyone thank you
for your continued work on this
important topic my name is Thomas valard
I'm the director of the division of
public protection at the New Hampshire
Attorney General's office but for close
to 25 years I was a criminal prosecutor
uh primarily in the straford County
Superior Court and for 16 of those years
was the um elected County attorney part
of my role as the uh one of the chief
law enforcement officers for a county
was to work with the courts for what we
all understood was something that
happened with some prevalence which was
the Spectre of perjury in court cases uh
that can certainly be in criminal cases
we're here today talking about family
cases so uh what I did and what I upon
information and belief my County
attorney colleagues did was we sat down
with the clerks of each of the uh County
Superior Courts and circuit courts and
said how are we going
to uh handle these complaints when we
believe that there has been something
that actually qualifies as perjury and I
have to say actually because perjury has
an incredibly high
standard of proof because there are five
different elements that must be met and
in my communications with the public in
regards to why aren't you going forward
with a perjury case it was typically
because of those five elements if you
look at chapter 641 there are a number
of crimes in there perjury is 641 colon
1 because it is the toughest one to
prove and it should be with those five
elements I can go through those with you
but I think you're familiar with them so
we sat down with the
clerks and uh were able to create a
funneling system where when a judge
recognized that something could be
perous it was sent to the county
attorney uh because it's a felony and uh
whether it was family court or any other
court and I rece I've received over the
years referrals from all the different
courts so I'll stick just with the
family court what we would do is we
would then assign it to an investigator
uh we would do interviews and we would
do a full criminal investigation into
whether uh that statement qualified as a
perous statement again if it was made
knowingly if when it was made it was
made with the belief that it was false
so it's not a mistaken statement it is
something that someone knows is false it
was made in an official proceeding it
was made under oath and probably the
hardest element is that it was material
that means it substantially affected the
outcome of that particular controversy
and quite frankly um even after due
investigation it was often found that U
it might have been uh a false swearing
or some other uh permutation of perjury
but um if it's being reported to this
committee that perjury is not being
looked at or prosecuted or is under
reported it might just be because it's
such a high mountain climb uh for
someone to be charged with perjury and
then to prove that perjury and it should
be it's a very serious crime so I just
wanted to uh attend this morning to
thank you for your continued work on
this to um offer my 25 years of uh
diance into this issue I've prosecuted
perjury cases before I've reviewed many
more than I've charged unfortunately
because of the high standard that
perjury requires in order to charge a
citizen of the State of New Hampshire
with a most serious crime which is
felony so I don't know if there are any
questions based on what I've presented
questions for yes uh represent pearon
thank you and thank you for taking my
question um I want to list the five
uh items that must be met I have knowing
it was a false statement it was made
under oath it was made in a public
hearing and was material to the case
what am I
missing those are four so uh you make a
false statement it must you must believe
it's false you know it's false okay it's
material two it's under oath and an
official proceeding and it's knowingly
the men's Ray is not in there but uh it
must be made knowingly men's race yeah
the mental state so it's its absence of
mistake
right yes repr
Beth thank you thank you for taking my
question um I'm really interested that
you yeah thank you repres thank you I
really do appreciate your service and
also that you have the the way you talk
about the judges referring to your
office and investigating thank you for
doing that I'm wondering about the other
um crimes that are listed um in 4641
like false swearing the UN un uh sorn
falsification and tampering with
Witnesses are because those are also I
think probably what the people that have
before you know appeared before this
committee it's not just we're using
perjury for a term that's actually a lot
broader are those also um crimes that
may be referred to your your former
office
um by the judges and are they also ones
that you would have investigated
absolutely thank you for asking that
question because perjury is a place to
start and then we would step down to for
example 6412 which is false swearing if
you line up the elements with perjury
you you see that false swearing is
almost the same as perjury but it you
don't need to prove materiality which
again is a very big issue when we're
we're talking about comparing statements
uh with with other statements that are
made so we would go through the whole
panop
um I also neglected to mention in my
initial statements that not just the
courts referred these cases but we would
take any citizen complaint at least in
straford County any citizen that
complained and believed that they were
not treated fairly by the court because
their opponent had entered in perjures
or or uh uh knowingly made false
statements into a court record we would
still open the same investigation um go
and pull the record and do those
interviews and conduct a full Criminal
inv instigations so and I don't again
upon information believe I believe my
other nine County attorney colleagues
thing yes questions representative ball
thank you chairman um just for
clarification where does um like filing
a false police report if you make an
accusation on a police report or you
actually follow through where does that
fall because that's something that we
heard quite a bit um of people coming in
testing toine so that's covered in 641
colon 4 false reports to law enforcement
um and it can also be covered in 6413
unsworn falsification so these would
then have uh you know one element less
which was it's not made in official
proceeding for example or some other
permutation but those are step Downs
again from perjury then false
swearing clarification yes follow go
ahead so just to clarify so you're
saying it's not made in a I'm sorry what
did it wasn't made in a um how did you
word that again an official proceeding
in an official but if the police record
is brought in as part of the official
proceeding or it's questioned or it's
now becomes part of the um testimony
isn't that then falling under the
perjury because now it is being claimed
in a
proceeding if it's a statement that's
sworn to in is material so then then he
would if you're talking about perjury so
now you're talking about an oral
statement from a report am I
understanding your question correctly so
the this false statement is made in a
police report and then is sworn to under
oath an official proceeding in his
material as a oral perjury statement yes
because the police report is then used
as part of the court case or it could be
used as part of the um where the child
custody is going to be or how things are
going to happen within the um Family
Court so it it finds its way into family
court and I think that's what people
came to testify is that but now it was a
false statement on a police report but
now it's being entered as part of the
proceedings in the family court and it's
being then used to withhold children
sometimes from a parent if the false
written statement through some colloquy
with that judge are you adopting that as
your testimony here because the person
would have to testify under oath that
the written statement is their testimony
and in that proceeding if that course of
action was taken then maybe that could
qualify as a pjur statement but
otherwise there' be two separate
analyses because if you're dealing with
um unsworn falsification that's a
written false statement so it it can't
be oral so it have to be adopted as an
oral statement under oath in an official
proceeding so what is the penalty for
filing a false police report that's a a
misdemeanor it can be handled in the
discretion of the prosecutor as an a
other questions uh representative
Smith thank you very much um and I'm I'm
going to expose my ignorance here um can
you tell me if there is any
difference
between uh the occurrences we're talking
about now in a civil matter versus in a
criminal matter is that the particular
issue irrelevant if you're looking
exclusively at the perjury thank you
representative Smith no it's it's the
same rules for any proceeding so
criminal civil family um these laws
would apply to any statement that is
made in a false Manner and then with the
other elements that are required for the
particular crime that could I follow up
of course yes um we also have over the
year or more that we've been trying to
sort out
this can of worms I don't know what else
to say um we frequently hear uh
reverence to concern that um the court
in question does not use Rules of
Evidence and we've had very clear
explanation of
why the court and the individual judges
consider that to be appropriate
in the Family
Court does that
reality when when you measure the costs
and the
benefits
um is
it appropriate to conclude that not
having Rules of
Evidence in this court helps us get
closer
to our goal of
Justice not having rules of evidence
strictly applied in family core seems to
to move the needle in the direction
towards being fair to folks who are so
often representing themselves and don't
understand the ins and outs of um
evidentiary rules as a criminal
practitioner I practiced under strict
rules of evidence and I can tell you
that um after almost every criminal
trail that I concluded I was convinced
that someone had committed perjury
because you could not line up the
testimonies right but the the big part
of the FactFinder is to rectify ify
those differences and those Shades
between two competing sets of of um
statements and determine who was more
credible so I don't believe that in and
of itself the suspension or the the
loose application of the Rules of
Evidence um leads us to uh some sort of
solution on this perjury issue and I do
think it's the fair way to treat people
particularly not just in Circuit Court
uh generally but certainly in family
court and if I could just ask one more
question the chair began um this work
session by asking for suggestions of how
we
could or not we how the court
system could be improved to even better
meet the needs of the citizens of the
state do you
have without you conferring with the
attorney general or the Chief Justice do
you have any
suggestions that um you would make
perhaps just for us to consider of
changes um that we might
encourage you I recently had the
opportunity to sit at the confirmation
hearing for one of the most recent
Circuit Court judges who's a good friend
of mine and I really enjoyed his
presentation in regards to why he wanted
to be a circuit court judge which was
you know the importance of really
listening in to the litigants before you
and making sure that you were hearing
them so that that art of active
listening uh and making sure that those
litigants are heard and have an
opportunity to
speak I think there are more and more
judges who are being appointed and
confirmed who are employing those
techniques and so the there's not this
tremendous wall between the the
litigants especially prosay litigant and
our judges that is going to that just in
and of itself is going to help improve
The public's perception of going to the
People's Court which is really what the
circuit court is and no more so than
family court where you're dealing with
the really the most custic and traumatic
issues that families can go through so I
I think that we're developing into a
scenario uh in the courts where the
judges are understanding more we really
do need to listen we can't just call
people up and be sitting 10 feet above
them and demand that they they State
there case in um very esoteric and
evidentiary based five minute
presentations and really solve the
problems of what families are going
through so um I don't want to do too
much padding on the back but um I think
the family courts come a long way in
regards to appoint uh having appointed
to it folks that understand the
complicated
issues I'm sorry could I just do one
more I find that that interesting
statement I wonder wonder if you could
support that in any way because a
concern that we hear repeated again and
again is that there are many fine
attorneys who are being um nominated and
confirmed for these courts but that does
not mean that they have had any
experience in the family court or any
meaningful training about how
this the issues in the Family Court
differ from those issues that are on uh
the table in other
courts yeah the training for attorneys
has been changing quite a bit if you
look at the selections of continuing leg
legal education classes for example it's
much more in the vein of uh not the
science of trying cases but the art of
negotiation and deal with people in
mediation and many more courses in
regards to what is actually going on in
people's lives you talk about substance
abuse mental health issues um the
complications of uh multigenerational
Families how to deal with all those
kinds of issues those things just in the
25 years that I've been practicing those
were unheard of um just a few years ago
but now we're all being exposed to it
and trying to understand that better in
order to serve the people that we're
coming in contact with and those judges
who those individuals who have been
nominated have all um been required to
um participate in those they're not I
don't know if they've been required to
but uh We've certainly been exposed to
it and there would have been a awful lot
more opportunity for folks to be taking
courses uh in those veins to understand
what's really going on before them thank
thank you very much for taking my
question again um just for clarification
um are you saying that you would support
the one judge uh one Court one judge as
opposed to having a family see multiple
judges um because you mentioned about
the importance of listening um and if
the cases moved from different judges
have they ever really heard the whole
case so that's that's the first part is
do you support one judge um one court
and then as a followup to that um then I
would be
asking so one of the one thing that
keeps coming in front of us is that the
the judges in Circuit Court don't have
clerks so there's no one even if they do
start moving around that the families
are seeing multiple judges who's really
gleaning through to remind the judge of
the previous conversations and what
could have been said um how is that
going to happen if we have no clerk so
I'm wondering what your suggestions
first of all how you feel about one
judge one court and then um also what do
we do about the fact that how are we
listening if the judge doesn't have
someone help them to go through and
glean through especially some of these
that I mean these divorce cases go on
for
years thank you sure uh having been um a
party in cases are go on for years I
always enjoyed having one judge rather
than having to refresh a new judge in
regards to what was going on in the last
proceeding there's certainly an
efficiency to that and there's also uh
some comfort unless that judge is not
with you at all in which case you you
would very much like to have a change in
uh in judges um but you know so there's
there's efficiency to it I think there's
also um a level of comfort that someone
actually is in a way your judge um I I
I'm not here to make recommendations or
suggestions but I can certainly share my
own practice point on that I would think
it would be also disorienting for
families to constantly see a different
judge and have to retell maybe some of
the traumatic things that have happened
um that might be the shortest way for an
inheriting judge to get him or herself
up to speed on a Case uh but there's
certainly a vicarious trauma there that
by all means should be
avoided um your second question the
second question was that there are no
clerks for the family court judges and
whether that's causing more harm um
because there's no way to get to remind
the judges I mean when you have stacks
this big who's leaning through that to
remind the judge of well this is what
was said in the is what would happening
and we're seeing a pattern or bringing
those things forward to the judge sure
well I you know this is a um maybe a
side symptom of uh as we are digitizing
everything we're asking judges to have
just as you have uh a a screen in front
of you ostensibly they have the entire
record at their disposal and can just
click and point and and understand all
that and and refresh themselves that
that's the way it's supposed to work it
doesn't always because of Technology
issues
um it puts a lot of pressure on judges
because judges are becoming more clerk
likee um as we continue to consolidate
down and we're we're staving off staff
um judges are doing more in regards to
having to run their own dockets and be
clerks so I think it's something for
this committee and other committees
working with the courts to keep an eye
on which is um it's already difficult
enough to make these decisions on cases
but to also have to manage all the
electronic doc
can be I'd imagine become
overwhelming thank you of course other
questions for this wit no I just I'm
sorry go go ahead representative Beth so
thank you no problem thank you for this
is it's really a repetitive question but
but since the people that are coming
before us this is I practically I wanted
to follow up on um my colleague
representative Ball's question before um
I think what I heard your testimony say
if someone an individual citizen were to
come to you and say Purge pery or what
they consider a false statement I think
when I was reading the statute I was so
surprised that perjury wasn't just a
false statement that it did have those
five elements and so really it's kind of
the the top of the hierarchy of these
false statements um and um so if if a
citizen would to complain to your office
or bring a complaint then your office
would investigate that and if it didn't
quite meet perjury there are the other
like five or six false statement crimes
that could be applied it might not me
the top but there were other crimes that
you would then investigate and prosecute
that's what you're saying so citizens do
have a way to come forward is that
correct absolutely yes and if I could
follow up so you were saying your nine
other CN Parts you believe this is how
they practice in their counties yes upon
information believe we all were doing
the same thing and so then that's a good
question as the elections approach for
people to talk to their County attorney
about or who's running for County
attorney to make sure that this is going
on in their office a very fair question
what's the what's your responsibity to
us trying to use a court and feeling
thwarted by being able to do so or at
least being able to do so fairly and if
there are laws that would allow for that
fairness to be increased um through the
possibility of of the application of
criminal offenses U what is your office
doing to to apply those crimes to my
scenario thank you thank you other
questions so I guess I just have one
question Mr valard and I'm wondering if
do you have any sense or any
suggestions in terms of the
perjury chapter of the rsas itself is
there anything there that you think
there should be some part of the statute
should be changed or there should be a
new statute to deal with you know to
deal with some of the things we're
talking about now oh thank you Mr
chairman no you know if you look at the
chapter on its whole in in regards to
written or oral statements it's pretty
exacting um as it should be because
we're talking about criminalizing
conduct and in some cases felon ising
conduct so should we should be pretty
specific but it really does
cover the vast majority if not all of
the scenarios that I've seen over the
years of competing statements and are
the was a mistake made in one statement
or a disagreement made between two
statements or did someone really make a
statement knowing it was
false uh and we know object ly what the
truth is and so that third example that
I just gave you is really difficult to
discern and then prove Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt um and so again back to
my original statement which is I think
the Under reporting of perjury or people
saying you know no one ever applies the
perjury statute there it may very well
have been reviewed by someone or and
they just simply felt that they could
not meet that high burden but the
chapter itself really does cover what
you would want it to have cover which is
you know obstructing police officers
from doing what they're supposed to be
doing telling untruth and official
proceedings either orally or through
written statements um those those are
the big ones and um I think the chapter
um is exacting as it should be and does
cover what we needed to cover I've not
seen any holes where I would say the
legislature should look at
XYZ it's it's all in there it just needs
to be applied and then need it needs to
be applied unfortunately to facts that
are so often incredibly murky um and and
that's maybe where the the breakdown in
the Public's eye I know from having
conversations with folks who have
referred perjury cases to me and I've
said this is why I can't go forward um
you know we've had to agree to disagree
sometimes in um heartily simply because
there's an evidentiary standard to
charge someone with a felony for perjury
that I I simply did not feel could be
met even though the statements were 90
degrees from each other um that does not
necessarily mean it it meets all the
those five
elements yes representative Pearson
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question uh in the other
committees that are similar to this um
we've been looking at the value of
having a small booklet that outlines
various things especially for prosay
litigant who may not know all these
things um will would a brief discussion
of what qualifies for
perjury be hopeful if it were added to
this document so that before people say
wait a minute that's perjury why aren't
they doing anything they may already
have the answer I realize I'm leading
the witness but could you answer anyway
I think any reference to uh to the rsas
is always helpful um I will I will tell
you that I actually teach this chapter
of the r
to the new police Cadets and and break
them down and we spend a good deal
amount of time talking about the
difference between perjury unsworn
falsification uh false reports of the
law enforcement officer and the
differences between them so they can
recognize them on the street when
they're trying to discern statements in
in real time so we I just use that as an
example of um you know it's helpful to
understand what is what are the rules in
order to apply so I would have to say
yes thank you reprentative
appreciate
that other questions thank you very
thank you very much Mr valard for very
much and thank you for your continued
work on these important
issues all right is there um anyone else
who uh wishes to to be heard yes please
come
up good morning Gail dret Amherst New
Hampshire thank you for allowing us to
talk today I'm not really prepared cuz
we thought there was no public testimony
but you guys have legislated the laws
there is no enforcement mechanism for
these laws um 6334 interference with
child custody this would alleviate a lot
of these problems for these parents and
I want to say I am not in Family Court I
haven't been in family
court but I'm involved with lots of
parents that have been and it is
horrifying for these children to lose
their childhood because these laws are
not being enforced you guys have done
your
job the Judiciary law enforcement they
have got to enforce the laws you guys
have made it's not fair for these
children and if there is an abuse
situation that needs to be dealt with
immediately you can't wait 6 months with
DCF you need psychological evaluation or
domestic violence child abuse evaluation
immediately they cannot go without
seeing one parent when there is these
false allegations it is harmful to
children they have lifelong detrimental
consequences they will not recover from
I mean we come before you time after
time and nothing gets resolve there's a
little fix here and there you got to
enforce the laws that you've already
made
these families are begging you I'm
begging you like I keep seeing these
parents the children what about the
children that's I ask that all the time
what about the children they don't get a
doover please do something for the
kids um 6334 again enforce it make an
enforcement mechanism you know charge
them if you have to nobody wants another
parent arrested but if that's what you
have to do you have to do it you can't
keep giving them discretion the judges
and the law enforcement discretion you
are ruining children's
lives please do something for these
kids questions for this
you
sorry what's that well well I think we I
want to hear from representative gay or
yeah oh can I get uh can I get a pink
card please yeah and representative G
you when if you fill out a pink card
when you're done thank you excuse me
okay Betty gay Salem um my concern is
that some of the places where false
statements are made are far more
detrimental than because they happen
more frequently than perjury in court uh
just as uh uh
was just mentioned earlier when people
file false statements either to DCF or
to the
police and then they're investigated and
that usually means that the parent that
they're filed against doesn't see their
child for X number of
months that that false statement when
it's found to be gra uh
unfounded that child and the parent
they're separated from have been
punished but the person who files the
false statement goes unpunished and it
turns into a pattern for some people
they play a game repeatedly and there's
no punishment so even though when we're
talking about uh perjury we're really
talking about court applications aren't
we but the most serious perjury occurs
long before it ever goes to court and it
happens frequently and and it's a tool
that manipulators use so I would hope
that we could apply some changes to the
law so that we can address that kind of
perjury even though it's technically
it's a false statement but there is no
penalty for it and it's used repeatedly
and it separates children from their
times uh I'll just add another concern
of mine even though I'm sure it doesn't
exactly tie to perjury but it's been
mentioned about one case one
judge the very fact that family court is
that is a law that is an RSA one Court
one one judge it's in Circuit
Court that's an
oxymoron that means you're going to get
a different judge so I would like to see
that fixed and applied
because it's just outrageous to pass a
follow I'm looking to see oh uh the idea
that in court perjury has all these five
requirements and then it makes a
distinction between written and spoken I
thought when you filed a written
statement that was legitimate I thought
that had the same
weight as I thought written and spoken
filed both had the same weight
apparently it doesn't so if anybody's
going to file a charge uh written I I
mean
spoken it sounds like unless they go and
sign
it it's not it doesn't have the same
standing in court so I'm kind of
discouraged that there's two separate uh
interpretation are two separate weights
to uh that you can't use a charge um
let's see if I can say it
better if somebody file calls and says
that they think something bad is
happening and it actually goes to
court they can submit a written
statement totally different so you can't
say oh you lied and got us in court
because it sounds like the written
statement
supersedes the the spoken
statement and so I I find that I I don't
agree with that I think that should be
clarified that if you're going to say
something that causes a great deal of
effort and Prosecuting or investigating
a
person
and it's it gets pretty hairy to figure
out if somebody intentionally did that
or accidentally did that I think people
will be a lot more careful with their
actions if they knew if
they they could no longer say well I
thought that but yet they triggered a
great deal of action that harmed the
person they were
accusing so I apologize that all these
are disparate facts or disparate con
concerns but they are they are concerns
that I think need to be addressed and
one of them
is is not telling the truth
before you get to court can be a whole
lot more harmful than waiting for court
to file it we're already going through a
great deal of suffering because of false
statements made to police and to
DCF all right thank other questions for
this
witness thank
you m Mr chairman would it be
appropriate to ask the gentleman from
the Attorney General's office to speak
to the issue of false statements that
result in a parent not seeing a child
for a long time that are later proven to
be false statements and what can be done
who can do
what sure Mr Mr valard do you have any
if you have anything additional that you
might offer on on
okay understand the question um it's
statements that are made in official
reports in regards to custodial matters
to the police or
DCF right and somewhere along the chain
a child is removed from the home uh from
one parent and that parent may not see
the child for months but later we
discover the statements that that
prompted the removal were clearly false
uh what recourse does the grieved party
have in that
case so typically those kinds of written
statements if qualifying would be
covered under unsworn
falsification so that's a statement uh
where it's a written or electronic false
statement which the person does not
believe to be true onor pursue into a
form bearing a notification authorized
by law to the effect that false
statements made therein are
punishable so if uh typically these kind
we we've added language like that to
most statement forms to say hey if
you're going to put this on
paper no matter what it's covering but
certainly if it's covering you know
parental
rights you are swearing to what you're
saying here and there's a penalty if we
find that you did not tell the truth so
that would be covered under unsworn
falsification which is applicable to any
proceeding criminal family
civil followup yes um okay then the
agreed party should next go where and
make what charge so that would be a a
report to law enforcement with uh with
where law enforcement will then ask so
your local police department or
Sheriff's Office where that agency will
ask for supporting documentation a a
notation to the docket number um likely
will pull the the written record to see
what happened um in regards to to um any
other supporting documentation uh so it'
be up to uh the citizen who wants to
refer this to to bring the supporting
documentation forward we would not have
as we meaning law enforcement would not
necessarily have the best visibility
into the matter because most of this is
confidential so there' be some
obligation to wave some of that
confidentiality to pursue an unsworn
falsification so there are choices that
have to be made I should have said that
earlier in my testimony which is we do
ask families to give up some of that
confidentiality and sometimes that keeps
people from wanting to report as well
this sounds like the river is trickling
down to something very very tiny um so
they go to the local police or the local
sheriff who then asks for documentation
and what usually happens next so they
take that documentation then they will
do an investigation in regards to
whether the statement on the
form uh was uh something that the person
who made the statement did not believe
to be true so that's that's very similar
to that's one of our perjury elements
right and that it's onor pursu to a form
bearing a
notification um that you must make
truthful statements so it's going to be
quantifying you made this statement
someone is saying that it's not true can
we prove Beyond a reasonable doubt that
when you made the statement you believed
it wasn't true again not a
mistake you made the statement on
October 1st by October 3rd you realized
that you had made a m made a mistake
because um you
know and you retract that
mistake so that you know there are
defenses to this as well but it's
something that you made on October 1st
you knew it was false and you're
somewhat recalcitrant in in or or
consistent in maintaining FAL
what then it would be U because it's a
misdemeanor it could very well be
prosecuted by um a circuit court
prosecutor so prosecutors who are
attached to the different police
departments um that is likely what would
happen and then um I very well aware my
my Circuit Court was the seventh circuit
so in Dover and Rochester I frequently
saw unsworn falsifications being
prosecuted by the Circuit Court
prosecutors I want to go back to the
word it was
frequently frequently frequently yes um
once again so many people who are upset
that their children were taken away they
can't didn't see them for a year and
everybody knew that what the statement
was was a blatant
lie um maybe they don't know the ropes
on what to do next but I'm hearing a lot
of grumbling of there was no justice
here there was a clear lie nothing
happened uh maybe they don't know what
to do next Maybe this should be in a
guide book or something yeah and the
grumbling could come because there's a
big disconnect between this separate
track that we're talking about which is
now we're going to criminalize the false
statement on a form go into Criminal
Court wait for that case to get resolved
and then go back to family court and say
look that person lied that we're talking
about months and months and months so
you know the folks that are using these
criminal statutes or at least trying to
um that is really more in the wake of
what has already happened in the family
court case uh it it's not something that
is utilitarian in regards to navigating
the family court so I don't want to
leave this committee with any impression
that there's some sort of realtime
Justice or rectification of a knowingly
made and believed to be made false
statement under oath uh in an official
proceeding it takes a long time for
these things to move through especially
through parallel proceedings criminal
and then going back to family and since
people know that they're not disinclined
regarding making false statements
because they kind of know it's going to
take a long time if ever and even if it
goes against somebody they're still not
going to get their kids back for a long
time I don't know that they know that
but that is the reality it simply takes
time to get sorted out okay thank you
sir of course other questions for this
witness yes representative
be thank you I I actually had a
different question question but um I'm
just curious if um
you the allegation that people make
false state or individuals would make a
false statement because they knew it
would take a long time I'm just curious
aren't the isn't that what judges are
doing is analyzing false statements I
know that my um chair Pearson said that
everybody knew it was false but if if
the judge knew it was false wouldn't
what what would h i mean in an Inc Court
statement that everyone knows is false
is it the judge's just do they have the
discretion or ability to handle that
without going to prosecution sure well
as the fact finder that would be an easy
fact to find um so he or she would have
done that already but then they would
have that discretion to make a referral
for sort of an extra punishment which is
not only am I going to find against you
because I find you to be patently
untruthful but now I'm going to refer
you for possible criminal prosecution
for perjury or some other crime of
dishonesty so I could follow up with one
more question I um and I'm not sure it's
um it's kind of
a the statement we heard before one
Court I mean one judge one case um and
um also what to put in the little
booklet that if we if that's produced um
what I've seen when people have uh
individual citizens have complained
about not having one judge generally
it's because they have filed an expart
or for an expedited hearing um so I'm
curious do you find within just your
county that and again I know you I'm
surprised how much you know about family
court but I appreciate that I'm asking
you to step out is it generally one
judge for one case in these you know
scheduled hearings and is it these
experties that are causing issues or
maybe an expedited or um and if so is
that something maybe to go in the
booklet exactly what is an experte you
know iMed you know the definition of
that and the impact that may have on
some of your other uh an individuals
other issues thank you appreciate the
question it's so granular that I'm not
sure I can answer it what I can answer
maybe a little more broadly is because
of the speed with which the courts are
moving because of the incredible
overburdensome dockets
litigants you know water finds a way
litigants find a way too to try to get
into court and so the use of EX pares
for maybe things that ex pares were not
intended for could be part of the issue
here too um so you know some instruction
in regard to what should an expar be
used for uh because that is ex anything
that's done on an expar basis puts a
huge burden on the court to get that
immediately scheduled which means
bumping other things the circuit court
has become um a very busy place
especially with felonies returning back
to it um so anything that can be done to
try to
streamline uh how the circuit court
dockets can be maintained on a
consistent basis is something that
should be looked
at other questions saying none thank you
again Mr fard thank you okay thank
you
uh Miss krian I do want to hear from you
but I'm if you can I just put you off
for just a moment sir if if you want to
come up very briefly really briefly to
address some specific point
yes so um I I'm I actually love the
conversation with various people that
just occurred because one of the things
that highlights is there's a concept of
polarity management versus problem
solution right so everything that we've
that that's discussed is how do you
solve the perjury problem the way what I
would frame to this committee is we have
two separate constitutional rights
issues when you talk about perjury and
you talk about criminal law you are now
talking about sixth amendment defendant
rights implicated right in Family Court
we have the 14 Amendment and due process
which fundamentally makes sure that due
process has to be followed in order for
your parental rights to be intact and
without that you have a problem so the
question that about these false
statements and what that means and what
what is the right statutory construction
is there the mental State men's Rea
they're all valid legal components but
what's occurring is you have a
conflation of constitutional rights that
are occurring so this entire due process
process uh that was described is
absolutely valid right and it's valid
because in order to account for sixth
amendment rights and defendant rights
that occur when you're implicating the
criminal system you have to follow those
things that that is a valid process if
you're going to say someone did
something Beyond A Reasonable Doubt
criminally but that is a separate issue
in terms of the polarity or the problem
we're trying to solve in family court is
how do you keep a parent's 14th
Amendment rights intact so our entire
statute construction approach needs to
account for what preserves 14th
Amendment due process rights so when a
parent makes an improper statement a
false statement do we have a statutory
construction mechanism specific to
Family Court proceedings under RSA
461 that impacts a parent custodial
rights when that that can be proven and
how does that occur from a preponderance
of evidence standard not a Beyond
reasonable out
standard separate from because today the
defendant rights from a sixth amendment
perspective don't apply in family court
because you're not in you're not under
criminal charges right you have a
combination of some weird amalgamation
of a court of equity and a court of
justice okay so given that you're
accounting for two separate statutes of
court of equity and court of justice how
do you account for due process so if a
parent makes a false statement do we
have an opportunity for statutory
construction or RC 461 parental rights
and responsibilities for example there's
numerous additions that have occurred
that are still not being carried out in
Family Court as an example if a parent
makes a an abuse allegation and they
truly believe that and they pursue
medical evaluations on that the updated
RSA as of 2018 or 19 if I'm not mistaken
states that parent cannot lose parental
rights however case laws such as Miller
versus Todd are still being cited
contrary to that statutory construction
as of the last session as of July 1st
you know effective Bill signed July 29th
it says that reunification therapy and
removing you know a parent a parents
right to see their children is
prohibited okay now are we going to see
judges appli that law so these statutory
construction changes that were occur
that are occurring one need to be
thought about in in the specific Juris
constitutional jurisdiction do we have
New Hampshire equivalent of the United
States Constitution that then goes down
to statutory law in New Hampshire right
that is clear to
judges is can't be counteracted by case
law right because what's occurred is you
have the statutary construction from a
public interest perspective is why you
created that statutary construction all
of the wonderful legal Minds then add
their case law to it and that statutory
construction has gone out the window so
what is our mechanism to fix that
statutory construction every time that
happens if that is no longer serving the
public interest all right thank you Miss
krian I wonder if you could come up for
up good morning
morning Aon crean general counsel for
the judicial branch sure and you know
I'm just wondering if you could tell us
based upon your um your experience and
your your role with the judicial branch
is there anything that you see in this
area of per you know the issue of sort
of perjury and family law cases where
you think that there's some
legislative uh um initiative that we
should undertake to you know to address
that
issue there there's nothing that the
courts are requesting but just as a
member of the public I I I do understand
that many victims
experience negative feelings working
with law enforcement trying to get the
evidence that will be persuasive to law
enforcement and trying to overcome that
Reasonable Doubt standard and although
our state's uh crime victim Bill of
Rights is very focused on the process
that victims get once a case is charged
their attendance of hearings whether
they have a a decision in The Plea um
there is not necessarily as much
legislative focus on what the rights are
before charge I do know that's something
that the house criminal justice
committee is uh considering I don't know
that what particular Avenues they're
looking at but to the extent that people
do not feel as though they have enough
transparency on on what law enforcement
is doing before the case is charged or
how they can interact with law
enforcement in a productive way and
bring their case forward and understand
what's happening um that's something
house criminal justice is looking at I
will say New Hampshire is probably one
of the better States for this we have
high high accountability in our public
offices and I'm sure that there are
people who are reporting crimes in
Chicago who have no idea whether that
case is going forward whether they've
given enough evidence or or anything
like the accountability that um attorney
valard is describing where he would
personally meet with citizens and
discuss with them their case um so I'm
not sure that there is necessarily a
very large Improvement to make but it's
something that this is a very responsive
government in New Hampshire and the
house criminal justice committee is
considering uh for folks that want to
bring their views forward there uh there
may be some Avenue that they would bring
forward but I think lot of the U
frustration that victims of crime
experience is gathering sufficient
evidence and meeting that high standard
of Reasonable Doubt and that is a
universal frustration of victims of
crime of all kinds of crime I wonder if
you could uh and I'm going to open it
for questions in a moment but I wonder
if you could on the this issue that and
that um and I know this is a little bit
off topic but may to the extent you can
you can address it this issue of of the
one one family one judge can you do you
have any sense of what where does that
stand so to speak in the circuit court
now great question so it's I believe
it's right in the statute that forms the
circuit court that it is ambition of the
Circuit Court to to honor that one judge
one family principle there is no failure
of will in the desire to implement that
principle there are logistical
challenges um one of the logistical Chen
the broads set logistical challenges is
a lot of turnover we we lost a very
large Public Service generation that of
Judges uh as they were coming up on
mandatory retirement ages and we are now
confirming a relatively large generation
that's that's just entering the courts
and that meant judges covering three or
four different courts um you know judge
Bole was driving anywhere he was needed
uh to make sure that the courts are open
and available and a judge is there um
for litigants who have scheduled court
cases but I think we were very impacted
by that change over people lost the
judge they had appeared in front of
potentially for years a new judge starts
maybe that judge does their first few
months in Manchester where there are
other experienced judges that they can
get advice from before they'll go to a
court where they'll be the only judge
present um so there there is a lot of
logistical challenge in that change over
but there is no failure of will uh
judges prefer to be on the same case to
know the case well just as prosecutors
prefer to stay on a case and just as
defense attorneys prefer to serve a
client all the way through a case uh
it's it's not an experience that a judge
enjoys being shuffled from case to case
it has just sometimes been a practical
necessity of making sure that the courts
are staffed and the judges are available
when the public needs
them thank you questions for for this
witness seeing none thank
you is there anyone else uh here that
wishes to be
heard all right seeing none then I'm
going to close the uh the receipt of
evidence part of this um and I guess I
would turn it over to uh discussion
about what if
anything um our recommendations should
be
regarding perer regarding this this
issue representative Pearson thank you
Mr chairman um I would put in our
recommendations the few items that were
previously flagged as being worthy of
inclusion in that booklet that's being
prepared um attorney KGAN and I have
spoken of this uh on numerous occasions
she believes that there's a group that
would be willing to work on this but uh
to me many of the failures and some of
the anger come because uh individuals
particularly prosay
litigant they're not lawyers they don't
know these things and so they get angry
because why was that done why why was
that not done what should I have done
differently and I realized there is some
information people can access ahead of
time if they are going to go prosay but
it's been my opinion all the way that um
there can be something uh more available
to people so I would say the couples of
things that we looked at what are the uh
what are the five points of proving
perjury was one of them I forget what
the other one was but um uh things
people need to know ahead of time now
there's always going to be some people
who are going to be angry for the simple
fact that they lost the case and they
are unwilling to believe they should
have lost the case and no amount of
reasoning will work I also believe
there's a number of people who would be
mollified if they actually knew reasons
behind things so that would be one
recommendation I would make for our
report so so point so some um and and
this I I have to confess my ignorance in
the sense that I'm I'm relatively new to
this to the overall committee I'm just I
I was only appointed um relatively far
along in the in the committee's work but
I if my if I'm understanding correctly
there's going to be the committee has
decided that they're going to they're
going to recommend that there be some
booklet
or pamphlet presented will contain
certain information for family L family
court litigant is that am my
understanding that correctly could we
sure good morning I know that uh you've
had a conversation with judge Christo
and and she has been a little bit more
partial to videos that explain certain
things to litigant we find that there
watched we have short videos on the
Court's website that explain certain
things she's younger than me that's
why perhaps perhaps I do not know if
that is it but um but there was also a
conversation we had about there are some
things the courts can't advise private
parties on because we are limited in our
ability to give direct legal advice to
the public and I did have a conversation
with the executive director of the bar
who is a former Circuit Court
Administrator about the the she has a
bit of fun fing for public education on
the law and I think often that Public
Funding is on things that are extremely
important but aspirational like for
example general principles of
constitutional law and state
constitutional law and I had suggested
to her that maybe some some of that
funding should be used for providing
public legal education on extremely
practical topics um like family law
which the bar is not limited in the same
way the court is and their ability to
give General Legal Information to the
public uh that that might be a way of
dissin ating more information for
self-represented litigants uh so there
there are a few things that we're
looking at in terms of helping
self-represented litigants to understand
the court system but we do have some
restrictions as well sure follow up oh
yes then um you've been making a list of
all of the things I've been asking to be
in this encyclopedia I trust I have an
entire folder in my email I believe you
do and um would it be appropriate if
after the session is over you Supply me
with this person's name and contact
information so that I can speak and
encourage with executive director blet
certainly thank you yes representative
Smith thank you Mr chair um what we've
just seen is one more example of the
incredible excuse me hard work that uh
the chair of the full committee um has
undertaken in this regard um and but the
actions that um chairman Pearson's
talking about I believe are actions that
he has taken
independently not in any way that are um
the result of the
final uh a final agreed upon version of
the committee report because we don't
have a final agreed upon version of the
committee report so kudos to Chairman
Pearson for not sitting around and
waiting um but taking action on his own
um I have a couple of
uh thing you're talking about Sarah blet
yes ma'am yeah
um
uh could you tell me why since the bar
association is not an in independent
body but is part of or membership in the
bar
is part of the Supreme Court um how the
do I think I'm trying to put my
theoretical underpinnings in the com in
the issue but the
courts the bar is somewhat independent
entity um it has a president it has an
executive director um it's not directly
controlled by the court system so the
difference if I I don't mean to
interrupt this the difference that I
completely misread is the difference
between membership in the
bar and the bar
association because you can you
know you
cannot New
Hampshire differs from many other states
where there is an independent bar there
is not an independent bar in New
Hampshire but you are saying that there
Association you have to be a member of
the bar order to practice in New
Hampshire uh and that wasn't always the
case and that isn't always the case in
every state and there there can be
competing bars um so you and by
practicing you are bringing yourself
under the jurisdiction of the Supreme
Court um but the bar association is not
strictly managed by the court system and
they do provide legal education over a
large number of areas that's very
helpful thank you very much and Sarah
blett um would be an excellent person to
um all right I I'll let the rest pass
for now thank you very much so I you
know I'm guess just I wonder if another
I don't disagree with the way you've
explained I wonder if another way to put
this would be yes we have an integrated
bar in New Hampshire in that you need to
be a member of the New Hampshire Bar
Association to practice law in New
Hampshire and the bar association is
ultimately regulated by the Supreme
Court but the Supreme Court does not at
least historically has not felt that it
has a really sort of
intrusive you know this will what this
is what you'll kind of do on a daily
basis sort of uh relationship with the
bar would that be a fair statement I I
think that's fair fa to say and I I I
guess what I would say is
constitutionally the entire practice of
law has to fall under the Supreme Court
but that does not mean everyone that is
practicing law is managed by the Supreme
Court so the bar Foundation is the court
is doing a lot of things that regulate
the practice of law in the state but
that does not mean that the bar
association is directly managed by the
court even though uh everyone there in
some way might be disciplined by the
Supreme Court for
misconduct um they're still they're
still an independent actor as many
people who are practicing law are
independent actors even though they're
answer answerable so the Supreme Court
is the ultimate Authority on the
practice of law in the I mean just you
know I just give an examp just just from
personal experience if you if your
experience is any different than this
please let us know but for all the time
that I was a judge in New Hampshire um
and and for even the longer time that I
was a a member of member of the bar of
New Hampshire I never remember a
circumstance in which the court ever for
example had a view on like who should be
elected president of the bar association
or was trying to you know either
directly or behind the scenes Lobby for
this candidate versus that candidate it
was to my it was always something that
was the bars you know they were going to
do whatever they were going to do and
the court would you know congratulate
whoever won and I I assume things have
not changed in that regard no they have
not the bar association functions
independently thank you very much if I
could I follow up um
I'm so
old-fashioned in so many ways including
um believing in three branches of
government and uh I know I'm stuffy and
all that but so let's just accept that
is I'm sitting on a legislative
committee not an advisory committee to
the judicial
branch and while I might have lots of
ideas about and I do about the way that
the court could better
function um I including how we
nominate judges which brings in another
branch of government um
nonetheless I
feel
restrained um in where this special
committee on the Family court
goes and what I see is that there is an
important role for the
legislature where the legislature has in
fact the Constitutional and legal
Authority um although it might not have
the financial
resources um to address certain
problems I begin with the whole process
for how how judges are nominated well
I'm not sure what we can do about that
but I then can see one issue that's come
up again and again and again we expect
Family Court judges to carry out
incredibly difficult
responsibilities ideally in a limited
period of time which doesn't work that
way and I believe we need at the moment
not necessarily to have more
judges but to have judges better
trained um before they um they sit in
family court and I wonder and I don't
know the answer to this question whether
it is within our Authority or not to
establish certain requirements
ments for uh as part of the judicial
nomination process my guess is the
legislature can't get involved in that
but I wonder about that um I then go to
where judges are
appointed confirmed and
serve and I believe very strongly that
and we've talked about this a lot that
there has to be a a lot more and regular
training
again I don't think that the legislature
can direct exactly what the contuct of
the training is but I do believe the
legislature could
say although I'll B it not in a time
when all the available money has been
spent in advance of the
bium um that that there is
uh going to be an
appropriation to be used specifically
and exclusively for
training on a regular basis I
believe that um it is appropriate again
through the budget process to insist not
on more judges but on more clerks and
support
staff um and to have money that is must
be used for that purpose and cannot be
transferred what I I'm taking too long
to say I know when you're all getting
restless is that there's very
little that we can do other than educate
ourselves about the genuine concerns
that people have about how the court
system operates there's little that we
can do in the legislative branch but
there there are things we can do I think
money when they say it's not the money
you know it's the money for education
for training for support staff all of
that I think is a role that we can play
and to the extent that the work that
we've done for over a year now under
chairman Pearson's leadership where we
have identified real concerns I think
that we can talk about those
concerns and present them as something
that um that bears watching so to speak
but understanding that it's not within
the power of the judici of the
legislative branch to control what the
judicial branch
does so I don't know if that makes
chairman Pearson unhappy or not but and
unhappy are you unhappy
uh no I'm not unhappy and thank you so
much for the uh kind remarks we had a
lot of conversations and we were very
much um I can't think of the technical
term I know incahoots with each other is
neither in law French nor current
collaborative collaborative thank you
very much uh there's a word for me to
learn now uh and we had a lot of
conversations uh we came in as an
outside pair of eyes and we went back
and forth and a lot of things happened
and that's wonderful I'm not sure how
much of that will ever get into the
final report of the special committee
and how much of the final report which
is not an LSR it's a report how many of
those items will then become lsrs in
November but I very much appreciate the
collaborative effort with the Judiciary
and amongst ourselves and a lot of good
things uh took place so I'm not unhappy
thank you for asking
may I may I make a comment briefly of
course absolutely I have no wish to
prolong your proceedings but I I just
want to say that this is an extremely
dedicated hardworking and conscientious
group of legislators and we have
received a large number of excellent
observations and suggestions um and I'm
thinking even of we're doing a pilot
program that starts in January which
will have uh Guardians Ed Lim we have
received Federal funding for Guardians
Ed lium to get appointments in four
different courts uh when they
demonstrate indigency uh which is part
of a suggestion a con conversation that
we've been having in this committee uh
we're doing a pilot program on text
notification that we're looking to
potentially broaden to some family
courts based on some of the questions
that some legislators have had about
notice and an email notice being missed
um this even if it is not a question of
whether there is a bill that needs to be
brought forward the observations the the
the the work that this committee has
done is is so appreciated because the
courts want to work for the people of
New Hampshire we want to do the things
that work and Serve the People of New
Hampshire and so your interest in doing
that and bringing forward these
suggestions is so appreciated um and uh
I I I don't find you to be the least bit
uh stuffy or old-fashioned
representative Smith you have had some
very very perceptive observations and we
have appreciated them see I missed the
opportunity I was going to say objection
facts not in evidence but I missed the
time all right um any other uh questions
or comments to this witness thank you
very much for for being here today Mr K
I really appreciate
it so uh yes representative so thank you
so um you had ask about recommendations
from the committee I I want to
underscore what um attorney cedon has
said I mean the conversation has been
very valuable and I think that um the
court is responding to things and the
public responds to things and we
individually as members just be even if
we are not making an action item
recommendation I want to say personally
I'm very grateful to be on the committee
I think I didn't understand the nature
and frequency of false statements that
are being made or the that that the
citizens feel they're being made and um
I'm understanding that a lot better um
but I when I then go to the statutes and
when I hear the testimony from the
Attorney General's office or from um Tom
valard in his previous career I really
see that the statutes are very
significant I mean um I think that
you know perjury is the you know
Hallmark and then there are other false
statements that are impacting the family
court but I think that they are
addressed by the not only by the statute
but by court rules that allow the judges
themselves either to not hear evidence
uh if they don't want to to admit if
people aren't providing like if you
don't provide financial information then
you can't contest the financial
information on that point you know by an
opposing party so I I do appreciate that
I also um the the false stat I want to I
I'm not a member of the collaborative
law Alliance right now but that is a
family that that's legislation that we
will be considering this year in the
house I believe and it's collaborative
is a type of mediation that has a mental
health professional as part of that
group and some of these false statements
can be addressed during that process and
you have a mental health counselor
really trying to help people gauge was
it is it a lie or is it a statement you
don't agree with and how we can address
that immediately going through the
process
and I think that in my experience
whether it's arguing with my adult
children about incidents of their
childhood it's not that I'm lying it's
that Our Truth is different our
perspective was different and um again
that's not always the case and I'm glad
we have law enforcement and and statutes
and but my recommendation um really for
this committee there aren't any action
items I think we've had a lot of
information um I think that the judicial
education and attorney education public
education I mean who could not be for
that um you know and I I wanted to there
was a comment earlier about um neuro
Divergent um Witnesses I think that's
very accurate I think that the bar um
does have some some education on that I
I don't know if judges I assume that
they do but that's critical um and that
was a good point of the the standards of
credibility that were using but I don't
think those are action items I think
that we've talked about it we've got
District Court represent here and um you
know just keeping the dialogue open um
and again it's an honor to be part of
this committee and I do apologize to
those my members the chair that I was
not here at the last meeting and that
there wasn't a quum that's a very
humbling embarrassing event in my life
but anyway I hope that we can be forward
positive on this thank you yes
representative
chairman I appreciate what everybody has
um said and I just as I'm sitting here
and having heard so much testimony over
the last two years um one of the things
that we found when we went into the cour
houses is that um there wasn't
necessarily A fairness from one
courtroom to the next depending upon the
perspective of the judge and and I'm not
finding fault with anyone and we did put
legislation through that would address
that um to make sure everyone was on the
same page but where I'm coming from is
that necessity to make sure that
regardless of which Courthouse a family
goes to or which judge they see they
should be coming out with the same
outcome regardless if if everything is
the same going in it should be pretty
close to the same coming out and so what
I heard was that there was um I think if
I and clarify correct me if I'm wrong
that in the one Courthouse they may
follow through with a false state and
there may be a misdemeanor or there may
be something my curiosity is is that
happening across the state is it
happening and following through in all
the in all of the different um
courtrooms that when a false statement
is made is is it being followed through
or is it just in that one particular
court I guess
that's I think that's where my head is
always is to make sure that we have
fairness across the board regardless of
which courtroom or which judge um a
person walks into so I'd be curious to
know in each of the cases or each of the
courtrooms how many of those um
misdemeanors for false statements how
many of them are made I just I would if
there's a way of getting that
curious I I well I'm sure we could get
information about like how many false
statement charges were brought in
various counties and you know uh I don't
know whether we'd be able to get the
information of when who made the
referral um but you know one thing I I
think it's really important to
understand is
that
the
the the
Ser judges the whole thing that judges
get paid for is to make decisions about
a large part of which is what is what
actually happened and so and often there
are conflicting conflicting versions of
what happened in fact if
I mean if there were if everybody agreed
on what all the facts were there
wouldn't be a case in the first place so
there's there there are often
conflicting versions of what happened
and that that's what a judge gets paid
for is to decide what happened I think
what is often overlooked in this is that
the basic remedy for false testimony is
that the judge doesn't believe the
testimony um that's you know the whether
or not I mean I it would seem to me I I
can as a having spent 18 years as a
trial judge there were numerous times um
when I didn't believe somebody's
testimony either because I thought it
was a m you know they were mistaken or
they didn't they didn't um they didn't
have sufficient opportunity to observe
something or whatever or sometimes
because they were ly they were lying but
what what I would do and I think what
what I'm I'm sure other judges would do
what when that happened is you're not
going to make a decision in based upon
something that you believe is false um
and so that it seems to me is the basic
remedy for for somebody who makes a
false statement
now if it is a situation where it's
there's a a really
blatant lie that it that seems pretty
obvious that would be able to be proved
that it was a lie um and it's worth
making the referral sure but I can I
guess I would say you would make the
referral but I guess I would say in 18
years of being a trial judge at a time
when we were doing family cases we it
was all the Superior Court handled all
the um divorce custody those kind of
cases I probably made a referral to uh
the attorney general or a county
attorney maybe two or three times um in
all those years and that's not because
it was only two or three times that
there was that I thought somebody was
not being candid with me it was just
that it you know it's not it's not
really worth it I wasn't going to make I
wasn't making a decision in favor of
somebody that I thought was not telling
the truth um and and most of the time it
wasn't really worth it and particularly
in family cases where there's a high
level of conflict unless it was really
absolutely clear to me that it was worth
making the referral
I often thought
look to to now send a referral so that
one of the parties to this family case
is now in addition to all the other
things that they're dealing with they're
now going to have to face a criminal
charge that is not going to help this
family and so very often I would end I
would end up you know I would simply I'd
make my decision based upon what what I
found to have happened without sort of
you know
complicating everybody's life by making
a referral for for some kind of criminal
prosecution and I I think I made the
right decision in do in in handling it
that way and I suspect that most judges
would would would would adopt the same
view on that that it really needs to be
very clear that there was a you know a
deliberate lie um that was on a serious
matter and that was it was likely that
you were going to be able to prove that
it would that it was a that um that that
the LIE occurred and it was material and
all the other elements were met and that
the ba the the benefit of doing that
outweighed the detriment and that was
often not the
case yes representative
Smith thank you Mr chair let me ask you
a
question um and I don't know which hat
you should put on but put on one of your
Myriad hats
um maybe we haven't been going about
this the right way at
all
maybe the question we should be
asking
is do these cases
belong in a court at all
is
there a another way a better
way that we can acknowledge the state
interest and find the tools
protect every member of the
family understanding our particular
responsibility to children
process is that throwing the baby at
with the bass water I mean do do do you
see what no I I do I do see what we
you're saying I guess I mean this is I I
speak only for myself on this I guess I
I think that the
that you could do that you could
certainly
have a non-c court kind of
administrative
process by which you would do this but I
think the it would it would seem to
me um that
that I'm not sure you'd gain very much
because I I think the the the issue is
in a in a divorce or or where there's a
dispute about custody or something like
that there's a dispute I mean people are
not in agreement and so so when people
are not in
agreement who should have who should
have custody of the child when should
the custody be there should there be
some restrict people are not in
agreement whether it's a court or an
administrative agency somebody is going
to have to make that decision um and and
I think you're you're you know you so
you're sort of back to my my concern
would be if let's suppose that you you
said we're going to handle all family
law disputes like this in in an
administrative tribunal of some time of
some type well first of all you'd have
to you know create that tribunal but
secondly I I what I'm what I think we
would be what we would be doing is five
years from now we would be having we be
having a hearing about whether you know
why is there why is there perjury in the
in the administrative processes in the
you know before the Department of Health
and Human Services or or whatever so I'm
and I and I so I I think that's would be
part of my answer and the other part of
my answer would be I I do
think
that whatever you know whatever changes
might be made and I'm not and I'm not
certainly not suggesting that that I
think it our selection process is
perfect I don't think that's true but I
guess I would say I think that the
care with which judges are selected now
and probably I'd say going back to
really when Governor Shaheen was uh was
governor and and I think she might have
been the first one to begin to use the
judicial selection commissions and I
think every Governor since then has um I
think that the care with which judges
are selected is at least as good and
probably better than the the process by
which administrative officials are are
selected and so that you know that gives
me some comfort thank
you representative B thank you again um
I just want to make a clarification in
my question or my observation I'm was
not finding fault with the judges what I
was trying to make the point is what
happens as it was brought up what's
happening in the statements that are
made before it even enters the courtroom
that's my concern and that's where it's
like well how do we keep
them just to put it in the words that
the people who came forward over the
last few years how do we keep the
weaponization out of the courtroom
that's the point I'm trying to get when
people are making these false claims and
that's why I'm saying and then they find
out their false claims what is what is
the consequence and that those are not
being brought into the courtroom as we
said can then drag out the court and in
the meantime the parents are losing
access to their children or just the
person who's had the false claims made
against them just what's happening to
the reputation and that's where I'm
getting concerned it's not that I'm
finding a fault with the judge or
anything it's how do we take the steps
before it even reaches to assure that um
there's fairness for everyone and and
like I guess that's and I apologize for
if I if I made it sound like I was
Finding fault with the No No I I didn't
interpret that way and I don't and in no
way take take offense of I I I didn't
interpret it that way but I guess I
think what what I'm sort of saying is
that even even in the you know in the
situation of somebody who fire who has
filed a complaint um and the claim is
the claim is that well it was false I'm
it often is not it it is often not the
situation that everybody agrees it was
false the you know it's it it I think
it's relative it's a relatively rare
situation where the person who makes the
false claim has kind of now conf I'm not
saying it never happens I think it does
happen but it's relatively rare that
that person is saying yep you know I did
I lied it's usually somebody else is
saying no that was not true um and you
know my my child was taken away for some
period of time because somebody in this
case you probably talking about somebody
at DCF believed that it was true um uh
but the person who made the com
complaint is is in all likelihood is is
still saying it was true and so somebody
you know it's a it I guess what I'm
really saying it's a decision somebody
has to make a decision was this true or
not true
and that that is often not an easy
decision to make that that's really kind
of what I'm saying it's not it
it we're get I think one of the things
that is a problem in
these in this area
is we get we
get information from people who have one
who have a perspective from one side of
a case and they may be entire understand
I'm not suggesting for a moment that
those people are
lying I'm just saying that we when when
we're asked to make decisions based upon
that I think it's important to that we
that we factor in about what we're going
to do that there may be another side of
the
story that we haven't heard and that's I
think that's
whereas the decision maker in that
whether it's the court or dcyf or
whatever they often have
heard the whole story and so they're you
know they may I think we need to we need
to factor that in to as to
whether what action we're going to take
heard we got to write a report
I guess what you know
I here's what my inclination would be in
terms of a subcommittee report is to
say there is there's no question that
Ury from time to time happens in family
law cases as it does in other cases and
and it may even be true that there's
more of it in family law cases because
those are you know I would be the first
to admit those are the highest conflict
kinds of cases there's no question that
the people people especially where
children are involved people are you
know uh that's that's
where emotions can run the highest
um
and but in terms of what
legislative actions we can take I I
would I have absolutely no issue
whatsoever chair Pearson with the idea
of you know providing more information
to litigants um if we can you know I I
as I say I'm a little bit late to the
process of what all the what all the
points that you and Miss crean have been
talking about that would go into a a a
booklet or pamphlet or but I certainly
have no problem
with having something be put in there
concerning like what is what are the
elements of the crimes that uh that um
can result from somebody making a false
statement whether in court or in some
other official proceedings as uh or or
uh documents that are filed and with
dcyf or whatever as Mr valard pointed
out and I also um completely agree with
uh with representative Smith on the you
know the advisability of having better
training and uh Educational Services for
judges with the caveat that you I think
you also recognized is
I think this is going to be a
challenging bium budget-wise um but to
the extent that uh that that is
something that is doable I'm completely
on board with that Mr chairman um I
don't know if you took the opportunity
to read the reports of previous
committees like this one um I have
others have I think the report that we
will be voting on a week from two
Tuesday uh is something that will be
looked at will be cited will be
informational to five or six years from
now when another special committee is
formed and much of what goes into
eventually seven different subcommittees
we've done four reports three are in the
process of winding up is to say we met
we looked at these things here's some
things we
find uh uh should be known wider a field
some of these are aspirational some of
them are educational some of them may
turn into
lsrs not from the committee but from
individuals perhaps on the committee or
even outside the committee that we sign
on as co-sponsors or what have you so
the report should really kind of reflect
the work we've done here and as I say
some of it is educational I think some
of it's
aspirational uh when the pot of gold has
been discovered here are certain things
that we would now suggest we actually go
do and and so on so I think that's what
we would need from this group before we
adjourn is a report that's uh brief like
that but has something to say not just
to people reading it now but down the
road all
right other uh comments um so I will um
I will try to uh put something together
sort of uh summarizing what we have just
discussed and I I know we're having
final committee meeting on October 22nd
I think y um and I I'll make sure I
circulated to the subcommittee you know
it'll uh it'll be it'll be short and to
the point uh but I'll try to do that as
as quickly as possible you know I just
would make one other point on that
particularly since we're we're focusing
on perjury I think that um
representative Smith's point about the
um judicial selection and that kind of
thing is really important because it
seems to me that there's a lot of things
that I think
training uh and education of Judges is
very important on I'm not sure that the
issue of perjury is one of those and
that's
because it seems to me it seems to me in
that the question of deciding what
happened who's telling me the truth and
who's not who's being accurate and who's
not being accurate who is lying
deliberately lying or
not I'm not sure that there's a lot of
training quote unquote that you can get
to decide that that's really based on
your life experience I mean you get that
kind of training in raising a child and
when they say you know when you say what
happened uh where did that cookie go um
uh and you get an answer and you you
know over life you you begin to and when
you go into the grocery store and you
know say what happened to somebody tells
you uh uh there's been a change in price
and why or whatever um all those things
in life are what kind of trains you to
make those kind of decisions and that's
why I think you know as a as a very good
colleague of mine uh I'm I'm H I'm
really proud to say she my my my former
colleague judge Conboy would say that's
why most of the time it's a good idea
for judges to have some gray hair before
they get appointed because they've had
some experience in life and they've
they're in a better position to be
making decisions about who's telling the
truth and who's lying and understanding
human motivations so that uh on the
issue of perjury I think that that's
so you will be pulling all of this
together sending it out to us for
comments back to you so the final report
will officially appear on the 22nd and
we will then vote on
it but the members of the committee will
see the draft of that before the 22nd I
should hope so I would hope so
too all right is there anything else uh
that we need to discuss I will try to
get a draft out
um by early next week anyway um uh and
I'll circulate it you know to the
committee the
I no I have not reading the interim
report kind of gives the form of what
the other three reports could possibly
look like they vary in length and
intensity and so on but they sort of
have a family relationship to each other
uh so we have four interim reports uh
four reports in the interim report and
we will be adding three more and they
could be like unto it oh sure sure know
will you can you send those to me can
you uh uh well that involves computers
so I'll I'll delegate that to somebody
all right thank you all right anything
else
thank you very much I'm going to close